what do you think about
the
rigorous testing of people to the degree
they're racist or not
the accusation of racism being a way
to attack to uh to bully
to divide
so what are the pros and cons of that
once again because it does reveal the
[ __ ] and the racists but it can now
hurt people
who are not well i think we have a
history here
in the united states
of blatant racism
that goes back a long way
and that has present day echoes
so
there are races i mean there are people
who look and see
all those are black people they're
they're patronizing this business i
don't want to patronize this business
anymore who if their daughter or their
son is dating somebody that is black
they will say i really wish you wouldn't
do that i mean why are you hanging out
with those people don't you know who
they are
uh there are people there are racists
okay there are black races
that is black people who see somebody
who's white and who then invoke a whole
lot of stereotypes or whatever or have a
you know visceral
dislike based upon nothing other than
the color of the person's skin such
people exist racism is a real thing etc
on the other hand
i think this uh throwing around you know
the accusation of racism
a college professor is teaching a course
he says in the context of teaching the
course
that
the
underrepresentation of blacks
in physics
uh program at this university is because
they score lower on the test
than other groups
and they're not qualified so say the
professor gives a lecture
and he says
we don't have more blacks in the physics
department at this university because
there are not enough qualified blacks
somebody in the
classroom who hears that a black student
objects he's a racist
okay
that's a power move
it's a move to try to control
the conversation
it's not an argument
it's an epithet
you've said that a person who has a
particular idea that you don't like
maybe that idea is i'm against
affirmative action i think it's unfair i
was just with dorian
abbott
dorian abbott is a scientist at the
university of chicago
who published a piece in newsweek
magazine
in which he said that he thought
affirmative action and
racial balancing
was unethical
he was invited to give a lecture at mit
a very distinguished lecture in his
field based on planetary
science i don't know exactly what it is
i'm not a scientist
but in any case
because he had said
that he didn't like affirmative action
and he thought affirmative action was
racist that's basically what he said why
are we looking at people based upon
their race and decide we should just do
it on the merit that was his position
now
people protesting at the university
where he was invited mit
saying that he's a racist because he had
that opinion he gets disinvited
charles murray
um is a popular
social science writer
who is famous for his book about iq
the bell curve
one chapter of which
chronicles the racial differences
between black and white
in performance on mental ability tests
and speculates
about the extent to which such
differences may be connected with the
genetic inheritance of these racially
distinct populations
now he could be wrong about everything
that he's saying
the southern poverty law center calls
him a white supremacist
because he
observes that there are racial
differences in
measured intellectual ability
amongst americans of different racial
descent
the i the you know he could be wrong let
me stipulate that he is wrong i mean i
don't want to argue about whether he's
right or about whether he's wrong
he's addressing himself to a factual
issue
and now the issue becomes instead of
grappling with the factual questions at
hand and demonstrating his rightness or
wrongness about those questions
the issue becomes his character he's a
racist
um
that's in my mind a lot like calling him
a witch
the use of that word now
i think
has parallels
to accusing people of witchcraft
because they have views about
substantive questions that bear on
racial inequality or racial difference
that uh a person finds unacceptable or
that a person disagrees with and you
think you can shut somebody up
um
crime
in the cities of
chicago st louis baltimore philadelphia
washington dc is out of control some
person might say murder rate is high
who's committing those crimes they're
mostly black
young men who are doing the carjackings
and who are doing the shootings they're
killing each other they're making our
city unlivable
now that's a hypothetical statement that
i offer
it might be correct
it might be incorrect it might be
appropriate it might be inappropriate it
may be true but something that we would
be better off if people didn't focus on
i don't know
responding to someone making that
statement have you seen what has
happened to my city
it used to be that you could go to north
michigan avenue and you could find one
after another after another high-end
shop this is in chicago my hometown
and
tourists would come and they'd go to the
theater and there were restaurants and
they'd go out they don't do it anymore
you know what half of those stores are
boarded up now you know why because when
george floyd was killed black people
mobbed in this city and they burnt and
they rioted and they looted and it
hasn't been the same ever since and i'm
moving to the suburbs i'll be damned if
i'm going to send my children to those
schools a person could say that
they might be right they might be wrong
to say it calling them a racist is
exactly not
a rebuttal of what they said
it's a move it's a move to try to take
control of the conversation
by accusing someone of having bad
character because they said something
that made you uncomfortable which you
can't deal with so you think you can
shut them up
by calling them a racist you might as
well be calling them a witch
you might as well be calling for their
head on a platter because they believe
that satan is lord
because that's the kind of
quote argument
close quote which is precisely not an
argument
that people who invoke that term are
using and here's what i have to say
about that
it's a fool's errand
to try to refute somebody
by calling them a witch likewise it's a
fool's errand
to try to rebut
the contrary forces in american politics
that are a reaction often
to real things that are going on on the
ground in black communities in the
cities across this country by calling
people a racist
you may shut them up
but you won't change their minds and you
know what at the end of the day they're
going to go to the ballot box and
they're going to vote
they're going to pick up their store
and they're going to move it to the
other side of town or to another town
altogether
they're going to keep their children
away from places where they think the
influences are harmful to those children
they may not even talk about it in
public you can believe that in private
that they're talking about it with each
other you had better find a more
effective way of dealing with the
conflicts in this country that fall
along racial fault lines than calling
people witches which is what this
um
you know anti-racist you're a racist
because you think that uh the out of
wedlock birth rate amongst black
americans is seven babies out of ten are
born to a woman without a husband
their families are falling apart now no
one says that in public because they'd
be called a racist if they said it in
public but as a matter of fact the
families are falling apart
you didn't change that in the least by
telling people to shut up about it
daniel patrick moynihan is called a
racist in the 1960s the late senator the
new york senator who was a
federal employee and intellectual
writing reports and he writes a report
about the negro family he called it in
those years if i use the word negro now
they're going to call me a racist if i'm
a white person i can't even use the word
negro
which is a historically
legitimate reference to the descendants
of the slaves
enslaved people which we were as black
americans proud to use until yesterday
so all of this linguistic policing
is a sign of weakness
it's false
black power
people will seed you the ground okay you
don't want me to use that word i won't
use that word anymore okay you don't
want me to talk about that in public all
right i won't talk about it in public
anymore i don't want to be called a
racist okay so i won't express my
opinion you haven't changed anybody's
mind
you know so
and you've also mentioned that
for that you haven't changed anybody's
mind but also for things like in
universities and institutions there's uh
diversity inclusion
and equity kind of meetings and
education and so on
and i believe i've read somewhere i've
been i'm like i mentioned to you offline
big fan of your glenn show people should
listen to it uh it's amazing um
there's also just interviews of you that
i've listened to i believe you mentioned
somewhere that even those kinds of
meetings people might sit through and
nod along
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
making progress
that they may not
they may actually be bottling up a
frustration that's the fear is that
that's going to result in a um
a pendulum pendulum
sort of push back towards this idea of
forced
uh
appreciation like forced anti-racism
kind of thing
uh i talk about this often in my pockets
that's the glen show you know and you
can find the glint show on my youtube
channel and also at sub stack
uh yeah you have a great sub stack you
you and your friend do q a's and all
that kind of stuff on patreon yeah so
yeah so people should definitely follow
you
but yeah i mean one concern is that uh
the um
uh policing of the superficial policing
this is a part of political correctness
you know the insistence that you only
use certain words that you only talk in
a certain way
it's a phony kind of power because it
doesn't actually persuade people about
the issues that are at hand
instead it forces them underground in
their talk about these issues and and
that's
uh uh that's problematic much better
that we have overt and explicit and
honest
disagreement to the extent that there
are disagreement
about things that are going on
then uh that we have a superficial kind
of
um
uh
new you know uh conversation that is uh
purged of
any real
biting
um uh you know
discomforting confrontation with with
the realities of the situation at hand
and for black americans i think one big
part of the reality of the situation at
hand
is violent crime
violent crime you know a police officer
is afraid when he stops the car because
it's an 18 year old driver in the
vehicle he's got dreadlocks he's a black
person the car doesn't have the right
license plate he's afraid to
deal with that person and one of the
reasons he's afraid to deal with them is
because a few who look like him are
behaving violently their violence is
usually perpetrated against others who
look like themselves but not always
and
that reality doesn't get changed by uh
you know uh telling a newspaper writer
who writes about it that they are a
racist or enforcing within a newsroom
you can't cover that story in that way
because to do so would be racist that
i i think
it's a monumental mistake
to um enforce
a closure on public discussion
based upon a calculation that if we
allow people if twitter allows this kind
of post
if the washington post runs this kind of
story
uh etc
you end up with
a
superficial
politeness
uh but uh a subterranean seething
resentment
uh that only makes matters worse
if i can get your comment maybe you have
ideas because it does seem that this
kind of attack
um works
of
being called a racist
being called um
maybe not sexist but somebody you know
like we're going through a johnny depp
trial now right uh it's a defamation
trial and the reason
it's a defamation trial is because all
it took was a single accusation of
johnny depp being somebody who
sexually and physically abused uh ever
heard and all he took is just a single
article
uh no proof was given
um
except the accusation itself and the
world believed it so
it's effective
so how do you fight back
if it's so damn effective that you can
just call anybody racist
and it works
it's hard to wash off
it's it's uh
uh
you're
you know you're not proven in the court
of law or anything like that but
we we
get those articles we get that label
and then the world moves on and just
assumes that person is racist so how how
do you do you have any ideas how to
fight back
no i don't frankly
um
just highlighting roseanne barr who made
this statement about valerie jarrett she
made some kind of ape like reference to
whatever
her show got cancelled and and and she's
a racist
so first of all pointing it out i
suppose is one of the most powerful
things that this the uh the hypocrisy of
it
the
you say it works i i guess you're right
it used to be the calling someone a
communist
yeah worked i mean going back to the
late 40s early 50s
red scare
mccarthyism
and whatnot and the person might have
belonged to a club that was pro-soviet
union in the 1930s when they were in
college they might have voted for the
socialist candidate henry wallace and
the presidential election of 1948 they
might belong to the communist party
they they might think karl marx was uh
right about a whole lot of stuff about
capitalism and whatnot and they got
called a communist or a marxist
and it could have ruined their career
could have ruined their lives
um
you know and a lot of people shut up
about it and it took and it went on for
a long time
uh and in a way in a way it kind of
still is going on i mean you call
somebody your marxists if you can make
that stick
they're certainly not going to get
elected president of the united states
but i don't know about this um
i think
you know
i once read this book by
a german political scientist called
elizabeth noel neumann
that was a
the writer's name elizabeth noel neumann
the book was called the spiral of
silence
and the argument was
there can be some views some issues in
society that get
uh defined in such a way that it's
inappropriate to hold those views
and as a result people who don't want to
be shamed who don't want to be
ostracized
don't express those views and when they
don't express them anybody holding the
view because they don't hear it said by
others think that they're the only one
or one of the few who hold the view and
so they don't want to be the only one
out there saying something so they keep
it to themselves so now
this view this attitude in society
could be held by a large number of
people
but because of the
fear
that if they were to express it they'd
be ostracized no one says it and since
no one is saying it the others who hold
the view don't know that they're not
alone
that they are not the only ones who hold
the view
uh and hence they keep silent that could
be an equilibrium it could be a
relatively stable situation in which the
emperor has no clothes everybody can see
that this dude is naked
okay but everybody thinks that you know
i don't want to be the only one to say
it and so we all kind of collaborate in
this charade
of keeping the view to ourselves
then along comes uh
an event
that
uh somebody decides to defy
the consensus
and to speak out
it could be a little kid who in the
story about the emperor has no clothes
doesn't realize that he's not supposed
to say that the emperor is naked
the thing about the kid in the story who
says that the emperor is naked it's not
that he's saying it
it's not even that other people hear him
saying it
it's that everybody knows that everybody
else heard him say it
okay
the kid who speaks out and says the
emperor has no clothes
creates a circumstance in which it's
common knowledge that the emperor has no
clothes now common knowledge does not
just mean knowledge
it does not even mean widespread
knowledge
it means comprehensive knowledge of
other person's knowledge of the thing
okay
so the spiral of silence is a
equilibrium that is susceptible to being
undermined
by a process of of a kind of cumulative
process a snowballing process of
revelation that you're not the only one
who thinks this way
okay
it's fascinating to think that there's
an ocean of common knowledge
that we're waiting for the little kid to
wake us up to different little parts of
it that's correct and the little kid by
the way could be somebody like donald
trump only more effective than donald
trump
somebody who is smarter than donald
trump somebody who is shrewder
than donald trump
somebody who figures out that when colin
kaepernick takes a knee at a football
game and says i'm not going to stand for
this present allegiance that
a vast number of people are
uh
very unhappy about that somebody who
understands that when a black lives
matter
activist stands up with his bald fist
and says burn this [ __ ] down about a
city in the united states of america
that a lot of people are upset about
that a lot of them
a person a shrewd politician a shrewd
manager of public image
could build on and create a circumstance
in which more and more people will feel
safe
to express that view and the more who
express it the safer those who have yet
to express it but who hold it
will feel in expressing it and to the
extent that the view is very widespread
but is kept under wraps
an explosion could happen and you can
look up it tomorrow and have a very
different country than you had
today
because the
conspiracy of silence the spiral of
silence
ends up getting um unraveled uh by
somebody who steps out away from the
consensus dares to take the slings and
arrows
of exposing themselves as a naysayer but
taps into a sentiment that's uh that's
very widespread and i fear that with
respect to
many racial issues
this is
the situation that we actually confront
that it could unravel in a very ugly way
you